hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game a lot of you have suggested to
me
and even though i wasn't uh i wasn't
planning on showing any games from the
melt weather champions chester new chess
classic before
uh the candidates tournament ends but
i've been receiving so many messages
about this game that you know my phone
will probably run out of memory
uh but not really you know there's too
much memory in in
phones today but really really a lot of
messages and
i knew that it was a great game even
before i checked it out but i i didn't
expect it to be this good and
yeah you know it feels uh well it feels
wrong
to upload a game on a sunday where
someone is suffering this much but
uh you know you guys wanted it so here
it is now pregnant versus sergey karakan
is from the round
five of the meltwater champions chester
that was played yesterday
uh so let's check it out the time form
it is rapid as the little robot in the
uh corner uh says uh so let's check it
out uh prague
with the white pieces opens with d4 that
we have knight to f6
c4 e6 and now knight to f3
uh we have b6 going for the queen's
indian defense
uh there's always you know ever since
alpha zero uh
sort of refuted the queen's indian
defense people don't play it all that
much but for a rapid game and maybe
blitz or bullet
you you can throw in uh a few lines now
and then so here now karakin will try to
throw prague a little surprise here we
have g3
uh also preparing to counter black slide
square bishop bishop to
a6 now first uh and b3 now defending the
c4 pawn so
now you don't have to worry about that
we have bishop to b4 with check bishop
to d2 and now uh
we go back with bishop to e7 and now we
claim that white's bishop is a little
bit odd here on d2
now we have knight to c3 and d5 now
striking in the center
captures on d5 captures and now bishop
to g2
yeah we have castles by both players so
castles castles and only now we have
bishop back to b7
and now uh both players have nicely
fiancarro did their light square bishop
so here
knight to e5 might beat the d7 attacking
this knight and bishop therefore now
and it's always uh difficult i remember
uh when i was still
uh you know learning uh well not maybe
learning the rules but i wanna when i
was starting to get
a little bit into chess theory and you
know i played against um
someone who played the d4 and then we go
into some sort of a queen's gambit
decline line and
they put a knight on e5 this always used
to annoy me because there's no way to
get rid of it i mean yeah
if you capture it then the pawn just
captures then you have to move the
knight then you lose all the defenses on
your king side
so it's a not an easy thing to deal with
and now we're going to see how uh how
kara can deals with it so first
rook to e8 and okay we have rook to c1
uh interestingly this has all been
played before so this is nothing new
uh and now knight to f8 uh we have
knight to b5 now putting pressure on the
c7 pawn here
and we defended with knight to e6 now so
everything's nicely defended if this
knight moves then
another attacker attacks c7 but it's not
a problem
uh we have knight to c6 now attacking
the queen and the bishop here
and of course we either capture or we go
queen to d7
queen to d7 is better now we're
threatening to win a piece here
uh and there is uh one game in the
database where queen to c2 was played
just adding more
uh defense to the knight on c6 but here
prague goes for knight captures on e7
with check
and it is only now as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game
uh so let's see uh what happens here we
have rook captures on e7
uh if you play queen captures then uh
well pretty much
that's a game over the rooks are under
attack and if knight captures rook
captures with an
attack on the queen and once the queen
moves we're gonna win the bishop on b7
so queen captures is not an option rook
captures however
is very good here because now you don't
really gain anything by this capture
because first black captures on f4 now
threatening knight captures on e2 with
check with a fork of his own so here
after we captured then
rook the c8 and then the knight is lost
and black just wins the game
so the same line does not apply here so
knight back to c3 by prague
and only now uh knight captures on f4 we
have g
captures on f4 and a5 now and yes
progress king's side has been weakened a
little bit but
he gained a beautiful outpost on e5 for
his knight and
this is what this game will be all about
uh as as you'll see so here e3
uh we have bishop to a6 attacking the
rook also improving the activity of the
uh
uh light square bishop rook to e1 and
now rook to
d8 uh we have rooked the c2 now uh
the c file is the only uh well not the
only but the only for white semi-open
file
so of course prog will shift to both
both of the rooks on the c
file to put pressure on that c7 pawn so
g6 and now queen to d2 making room for
the
for the e rook we have h5 and now rook
e to c1 uh we have h4 preparing h3 the
queen also defends the h3 square and now
uh
prague goes h3 himself so
not to allow black to do that so here
queen to f5
and now comes knight to a4 and now if
you look at this position you will
soon realize uh why uh black is
suffering so much black doesn't really
have a
a good way of dealing with the position
because uh
all of for example g5 and the g4 squares
are taken care of here by white and
there's no way for the queen to
infiltrate
uh yes you could throw in your knight
for example knight to e4 but it doesn't
really do anything there where
of course we're not gonna capture it
we're just gonna move the queen and
the the knight doesn't really have a
useful uh
a useful maneuver from there there's no
square where the knight can go to for
for the rest of the game there is no way
for the rooks to get
activated and well this bishop is strong
for the moment but
we have plans for that bishop bishop the
f1 can be played and then the dark
square bishop will not really be doing
all that much
so that being said i know a lot of you
just want to get this knife to the e4
but it doesn't really do anything so
here rook d to d7
we have to add more defense to the c7
pawn and
now comes queen to d1 we have king to g7
and now knight to b2 the knight is now
being remaneuvered over to e5 and when
this knight comes to e5
uh it will definitely be promoted to to
a monster knight
so here uh king to h6 rook to c6 now
grabbing more space with this rook of
course uh sergey will not allow it
he pushes the rook back bishop to b5
broke back to c2 and now
bishop back to a6 uh black really has no
active plan here he can only
wait and see what white will do so here
king to h2
improving the position of the white king
a little bit king g7 sergey just
repeating here and the bishop to f1 now
and with this move we're basically
saying okay you either move back and
then this bishop will be doing nothing
for the rest of the game or trade
bishops and then uh
well you will no longer have any active
pieces left because
uh it's really uh it's really weird but
this knight on e4 although it's a
beautiful square for the knight
doesn't really do anything in this game
so here we have bishop captures on f1
queen captures and knight the e4 yes an
excellent square for the knight but as
you'll see
that's all there that's that's all that
it is so here
rook to c6 now nothing can chase away
our rook from the
from the sixth rank and now king to f8
again
no active moves for black knight to d3
now coming to e5 and f6 now taking away
this square from the knight so
obviously that's not that's not
happening or maybe it is we'll see what
happens
uh so here rook to c2 uh now just the
defending uh the second rank
so your pieces can now move the knight
captures on f2 will never be an issue
king the e8 uh and now comes queen to g2
so what is queen to g2 what what
what is this movie even doing well yeah
it's it's uh well it's a surprise
so here we have knights to d6 by sergey
and
now comes the move that uh everyone was
uh so impressed uh when when it was
played uh and that move of course is
knight to e5 and this is just a
beautiful move
uh it's uh the the knight comes to e5
regardless of the f6 pawn being here and
uh
it's not easy to decline this you kind
of have to capture it
because your rook is under attack if you
move the rook uh we can briefly show
what happens just queen captures on g6
and that's it
if you know queen captures knight
captures the rook is under attack
rook g7 now we can even play f5 we give
up this pawn
uh as to activate the district and after
knight captures rook captures uh it's uh
well
we're only up one pawn but we're you
know so much better for example rook f7
if you want to trade rookie six
check these are these scores are covered
by the knight if king the
d7 rook uh e to c6 now attacking the c7
pawn and once king c8 is played so
both of these both the king and the rook
defend the c7 pawn now we play knight to
e5
and it's uh such a such a great position
for white you you don't have to even
play that you can even grab the pawn
here's another up two pawns and the
the rest will soon follow so after
knight the e5 there's only one move for
kaioken and that's
f captures an e5 and okay we have d
captures on e5 now attacking the knight
and knight to e for now uh so can
uh can black do something now is the
knight doing anything on e4
can the queen do anything because like
we said or these two
very important squares are are
controlled by white uh and
can the rooks do anything i mean you
have rooks uh controlling the
entire seventh rank but they're not
really part of this game they're they're
basically just defending that c7 pawn so
here
rook captures and g6 and now again uh
there are
threats lurking here if you're not
careful if you say okay let's just start
expanding you know c5 and then we
you know push some pawns uh you
immediately lose to rook to g8 to check
problem is after king to f7 and queen to
g7
check king that e6 now you run into
queen to h6
check and now there are no more squares
for the uh for the king
uh if you go king to f7 then just rook
to f8 this checkmate so you're gonna
have to block with something and then
you're gonna have to start giving away
pieces and that's just no way to play
you you don't even have to capture it
you can play this threat and this i mean
that's just uh
terrible if if rook the b7 defending
we're just going to play e4
attack the queen here and now of course
if the queen moves we have a nice queen
captures an f6
so we're going to have to capture this
and now rook to d2 and
i mean this is just amazing the position
has so much hidden potential that
was never seen in the game because it's
it's a rapid game but it's uh
you know definitely we should explore it
rook captures rook to d6 with
czech king to f7 and now well the
easiest way is just to grab the queen
captures and the other rook will fall as
well captures captures with
check uh it doesn't really matter if you
go here this rook falls if you go here
or here then this rook falls
checking the seven queen captures on v8
uh really amazing stuff
so instead after this rook captures and
g6 was played we have king to d8
karakin of course uh was not uh named
minister of defense uh for his
lack of defensive skills and now uh if
rooked
uh g8 check you can simply block with
this rook this is in fact what happened
in the game
we have rook g8 check rook 8 captures
captures
and now queen to g8 with check and again
if you go king to e7 that's not really
good just rook to c6
and rook to f6 is coming that's again
not much
you can do here for example knight to c5
we're just going to bring the rook to f6
and if the queen moves
then just queen to f8 to checkmate there
are also sorts of nasty plans here for
white
so instead after queen to g8 to check we
have queen to f8 blocking
now comes queen to e6 with check and now
you could
move the king you could block with the
rook you could block with the queen uh
blocking with the rook doesn't really
work because queen to c6 check and now
after king to f7 just queen captures and
d5 with check then we pick up the knight
and then we're just up too much material
in a much better position
one thing you could do is block with the
queen i think if if this happened then
we would have to go for some sort of a
either repetition queen g6 check queen
f7
and then okay not repetition but then
maybe we shift the queen to c6 and then
we continue pushing
because like we said black has no active
plans here black can only suffer
uh you know until white says otherwise
but okay here
carter can play king to d8 and now we
have queen to c6
and uh here we have knight to c5
now blocking the the the rooks reach to
the c7 pawn so you don't really have to
worry about anything
uh and here uh okay how do you continue
playing this with white yes you have
some pawns you can push them but
not for for the moment not really so
here uh prague
finds a way to activate his rook rook to
c1 now he wants to shift the rook to the
only open file on the board that is the
g
file and the karakan starts pushing d4
he says all right you've had your fun
now it's my turn uh let's let's finish
this uh prague ignores this pawn
plays rook to g1 and now is the moment
where
karakin slipped and it's very
interesting i think prague had like 30
something seconds on the clock and the
sergey had like a minute and a half but
uh still uh the the correct move is king
to e7
uh it's a weird move to play but you
know it's it's definitely the way to go
but here he played the d3 he said all
right why not just win the game right
away
but now he missed one very important
tactic from prague
so feel free to pause the video and win
this game uh for uh prague
pragananda while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
nope this does not work however if we uh
you know deflect the queen
one step further to the right then it
works so congratulations to everyone who
found it
uh for and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's of course
rook to g8 and this is just awesome
here you can basically resign but of
course uh sergey will not do that he's
much better on time and it's a rapid
game
so queen captures on g8 was played and
only now
queen to e8 with check king to e7 and
now queen captures and g8
and now what are you gonna do okay you
still have some counter play you have
the knight you have the rook and you
have the past deep on
but how to continue here first rook to
d8
uh if you go if you go d2 then f5 is
extremely strong and then if we bring a
queen into the game
problem is f6 is checkmate so that i
mean
it's terrible as it is even though this
pawn is so close to queening we can't
just start pushing it and this is just a
horror when something like this happens
to you in the game
so first rook the d8 uh pushing back the
queen and trying to get the king to
safety if you can get your
king here and then push the pawn could
be could be great but
queen to g7 check of course prague will
not allow this king to e6
now comes f5 with check and the problem
is if you capture this then
you just give up the game uh queen f6
checking here then a nice
check all the way to here then we pick
up the rook and it doesn't really matter
the point can easily be captured so you
know there's really no counter play here
so after f5 check we have king to d5 but
it's not a problem just e6 and it was in
this position on mu52 that sergey
karakin resigned in the game
and this this beautiful masterpiece was
created by pragananda for us to enjoy on
this
on this great sunday uh so here you
resign uh
because there's really nothing to do if
you just advance the pawn just
queen to d4 with check wins the game it
doesn't matter that the rook defends it
because first we're gonna grab the rook
and then we're gonna still be defending
the queening square
and if you don't do this there's really
not much to try you can try king to c6
yes
it does seem like you're on to something
here but d7 is much faster
if rook the e8 just queen to f7 and now
it doesn't matter if we push the pawn
queen captures rook comes with check and
we're never queening this pawn
so really really exciting stuff or or
you you could play
night the for example knight here but uh
queen the a8
check just you know uh connects very
nicely wherever the king moves we can
just play quinta uh
queen to f3 for example we guard the
queening square and you know
there are so many ways to win this
doesn't it doesn't really matter what
white plays
uh but yeah after e6 akarikan resigned
and uh
wow what a game indeed and thank you
guys for suggesting it
now it's it's so funny that i know by
the amount of messages i received the
the quality of the game and here
i definitely knew it was gonna be uh you
know just a brilliant positional
masterpiece we can
i know you guys will want it so okay
it's a sunday let's
let's do it uh there you go uh in nice
uh
nice nice the e5 in slow motion there
you have it
there you go uh so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank daniel
silverberg and matthew benoit
happy birthday to brad rice raffle
karanath and tiberius for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day